bonsoir Le 7 8 politique fait ça
rentrait une fois par mois je vous
retrouverai dorénavant sur cette antenne
pour évoquer les principaux dossiers du
département yvelinois de la région
francilienne deux entretiens ce soir
deux invités Jean pollution le président
PS de la Région Île-de-France et Pierre
Bédier le président UMP du conseil
général des Yvelines mais tout d'abord
ces images de la nouvelle école en
sciences politiques la première créée
depuis plus de 20 ans en France la
première promotion de Sciences Po
Saint-Germain les 80 élèves a découvert
l'établissement le 10 septembre jusqu'à
récemment ses locaux accueillaient
l'Institut de Formation des Maîtres
l'ouverture de cette IEP le second de la
région se fait selon à sa directrice
avec la volonté d'encourager la
diversité les enfants de milieu modeste
les jeunes issus des classes moyennes
seront encadrées avant de passer donc de
réussir ce concours la formation se
déroule en 5 ans si on se pose
Saint-Germain et le résultat d'un
travail commun entre les universités de
Cergy-Pontoise et de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
nous partons à présent pour Paris ou
Jean polluchon président socialiste de
la région a reçu la presse pour sa
traditionnelle conférence de rentrée
transport éducation prochain rendez-vous
électoraux ont été abordés voici son
interview
le président socialiste de la région
Île-de-France qui ne reçoit dansé locaux
parisiens bonjour Jean Paul Huchon vous
venez de tenir votre conférence de
presse de rentrée exercice habituel à
cette période de l'année on va parler du
question lycée parce que c'était le
thème de cette conférence auparavant je
reviens sur un une phrase de votre
discours vous avez dit tout à l'heure il
faut faire vivre l'espoir il y a de
l'espoir en cette rentrée oui je pense
que la situation économique et sociale
est très très inquiétante la situation
mondiale d'équilibre des forces
l'Ukraine le Proche-Orient ça c'est très
inquiétant mais il nous ici nous
essayons de redonner de l'espoir parce
que on essaye d'instaurer un rapport de
confiance et de conviction entre nous et
les citoyens d'Île-de-France comme
l'Île-de-France souffre un peu moins que
les autres de la situation économique
comme nous avons par ailleurs nous
allons développer une compétence très
forte en de développement économique
comme par ailleurs on investit en
continu à investir et on a pas ralenti
notre investissement aussi bien matière
de lycée de formation et de transport je
pense qu'on peut rétablir une grande
partie de la confiance ici en
Île-de-France et concernant la région
évidemment ça n'est pas l'ensemble de la
du spectre politique et il y a
évidemment la politique nationale moi je
pense que ce qui manquait à notre
politique nationale c'était peut-être
une certaine forme de clarté et de
continuité je pense que maintenant on a
choisi et par conséquent je crois qu'il
faut s'inscrire dans cette continuité et
puis en attendre les résultats si on
regarde justement l'échiquier politique
et la gauche la composition de la gauche
ou l'évoquais avec ce remaniement très
très récent vous vous situez où gauche
de la gauche plutôt dans la branche qui
avait été menée choisie par le président
Hollande si vous faut faire un choix
dans votre famille politique
j'étais en gardien
François Hollande c'est notre Président
je suis moi clairement réformiste mais
je fais toujours très attention à ce
qu'on ne perde pas le contact avec
la population et donc on puisse lui
démontrer ici que la confiance existe
toujours c'est à dire que ce que nous
avons annoncé nous le faisons on en
vient à l'éducation on en vient au lycée
c'est l'heure de la rentrée et déjà la
hache de guerre est à nouveau déterrée
entre vous et Valérie Pécresse puisque
sa tenue une conférence de presse la
veille de la vôtre et puis elle vous
accuse de réduire les investissements en
faveur des lycées elle pointe des
retards également dans les chantiers
vous vous dites l'inverse vous dites
elle a mal lu les dossiers elle se
trompe oui bah de toute manière si elle
était plus souvent au conseil régional
elle verrait peut-être passer les
dossiers et les décisions
franchement il y a beaucoup derrière
tout ça il y a beaucoup
je vais dire d'approximation
d'incompétence de mensonges aussi effet
détestable de travailler comme ça on
peut critiquer telle ou telle chose que
nous faisons mais encore faut-il ne pas
mentir et on t'aimant et c'est ce
qu'elle fait et puis en plus en faisant
de gros erreurs ce que vous appelez
l'âge d'abandage pour moi pour moi c'est
plutôt un sabre de bois et je crois
qu'on peut dire maintenant que dans la
plupart des lycées il y a il y a
maintenant
un niveau d'équipement
équipement y compris informatique
qui est devenu
très honorable vous êtes en poste depuis
98 ans si je ne fais pas d'erreur c'est
pas forcément l'heure du bilan mais en
tout cas vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
apporté quoi à cette région et puis il
vous reste quoi encore à accomplir dans
cette région à cette région je crois
nous l'avons fait exister avant elle
était considérée comme quantité
négligeable elle avait très peu de
véritables compétences et elle avait pas
de moyens aujourd'hui c'est un budget de
5 milliards le plus grand budget des
régions françaises et c'est aussi
plus de 200 chantiers de lycée qui sont
achevés ou en voie de s'achever sur les
ce qui est quand même un effort
considérable c'est aussi surtout la
réussite du Grand Paris c'est-à-dire
qu'à partir du moment où on s'est mis
d'accord sur cette affaire c'est comme
le le plus important du monde qui va se
réaliser autour de Paris avec une
attractivité bien plus forte pour la
région d'ailleurs moi je le vois bien
sous les dents la vie quotidienne dans
les rapports avec mes interlocuteurs
maintenant la région est considérée
comme à l'interlocuteur non seulement à
part entière mais au fond dans bien des
domaines nous faisons presque plus que
l'État et ça c'est ce que nous avons
changé en vérité et puis je crois que
nous avons aussi rapproché la région des
habitants c'est plus un espèce de
d'échelon
lointain stratégique mais c'est aussi un
échelon qui intervient dans la vie
quotidienne des anges je sors du
festival Rock en Seine il y a 120
000 personnes qui sont venues pas
seulement des jeunes et c'est la région
qui a permis que ça se fasse donc dans
tous les domaines et de la même manière
quand je vois en matière de sport la
base de loisirs c'est la région qui l'a
construit pour essentiel le fameux
vélodrome de Saint-Quentin on dit que
les épreuves du championnat du monde du
cyclisme en se tenir à l'année prochaine
passer la région qu'il a vu ensemble en
grande partie donc je pense que nous
avons maintenant un vrai impact sur la
vie quotidienne des francilien il le
savent et au fond ça leur permet de ne
pas configurer la politique régionale
complètement à l'aune de la politique
nationale est-ce que vous êtes en
campagne vous comme Valérie Pécresse je
suis pas en campagne parce que d'abord
la campagne n'est pas lancée et que la
date de l'élection n'est pas encore ce
serait décembre 2015 a priori vous voyez
que ça laisse quand même du temps une
campe les campagnes on a jamais intérêt
à ce qu'elle soit hyper longue
d'ailleurs le public le comprendrait pas
elle publie en ce moment il est plus
intéressé je pense aux résultats
économiques
et sociaux qu'on enregistre dans le pays
que pour une campagne régionale fut-elle
passionnante vous parliez de cet impact
sur la vie quotidienne des Franciliens
il a forcément cette question des
transports aussi les transports qui sont
souvent critiqués il y a de gros
investissements qui sont réalisés par la
région ça n'empêche pas certains
utilisateurs ceux de la ligne 1
notamment de vous interpeller et vous
ont adresser pendant l'été si les choses
ne s'améliorent pas c'est ce qu'ils
disent ils présenteront une liste
d'ailleurs on y revient au prochain
élections quelles réponses vous pouvez
leur faire et puis quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui pour les
transports globalement franciliens
de la région sur le réseau existant
prévoir la rénovation de tous les RER et
en particulier aussi bien au niveau du
matériel que des infrastructures et que
par conséquent les décisions sont prises
les financements sont là et pour le rera
c'est à la fois du nouveau matériel qui
arrive à ils ont de deux ou trois rames
chaque mois et ça va ça commence à se
voir dans cette forme de lieu pour la
ligne 13 qui était totalement saturé la
ligne 14 qui double
va prendre son envol au début de l'année
prochaine
et sur les tramways on aura pratiquement
accompli parcours des tramways à la fin
de l'année 2015 donc vous voyez que dans
le quotidien on est très présent et puis
il y a cette affaire de la
tailleification sur laquelle je me bats
pour que les franciliens et tous une
espèce de carte d'identité qui circule à
égalité donc c'est à dire le même prix
pour tout le monde quel que soit le
nombre de zones qu'il n'y ait plus de
zones voilà tout simplement aujourd'hui
honnêtement dans les transports c'est
principalement la grande banlieue qui
est défavorisée donc il faut faire ça
de manière à ce que le rapport qualité
prix du transport soit honorable merci
Jean pollution de nous avoir accueilli
ici
le 7 8 politique qui se poursuit
deuxième entretien à suivre celui mené
par Catherine zulato avec Pierre Bellier
le président UMP du conseil général des
Yvelines évoque lui aussi l'avenir des
lycées plus généralement elle est
compétence des départements alors que la
question de leur avenir reste toujours
floue
bonjour vous êtes présents du Conseil
Général des Yvelines on se trouve ici
sur le site du nouveau collège d'Achères
et j'ai envie de dire c'est un peu un
site emblématique puisque ça signe un
peu la fin des collèges vous avez appelé
les collèges milles alors pour dire
c'est la fin des collèges Mila il y a
plus de collège qui accueillent
millénaire dans le département il y a 30
ans de ça dans le département des
Yvelines sur les 85 collèges qu'avaient
le département il y en avait 18 plus de
20% qui avait plus de 1000 élèves et ça
voulait dire des classes surchargées des
équipements avec des préfabriqués dans
les cours etc donc ça y est c'est fini
on aura mis 30 ans grâce à la
décentralisation je précise aussi pour
ce peut-être qu'ils ne le savent pas que
les collèges dépendent du conseil
général collège dépend de du département
les lycées dépendent de la région et
j'appelle de mes vœux que les lycées
dépendent des départements ils seront
mieux gérés on va continuer à parler
décolles le numérique c'est une filière
d'avenir c'est pas moi qui me dis sont
les chefs d'entreprise qui l'ont dit à
l'occasion d'université d'été du Medef
qui s'est tenu fin août à Jouy en ça
veut dire qu'il faut associer les jeunes
au plus vite à ces nouvelles
technologies et les collèges du
département sont tous équipés en
numérique aujourd'hui et le numérique
c'est une révolution permanente donc on
change de technologie il y a 10 ans en
équipait exclusivement un ordinateur
c'était déjà un must aujourd'hui nous
sommes en train de tester et on va le
tester aussi dans ce collège les
tablettes numériques qui sont à nouveau
produit hybride entre l'ordinateur et le
smartphone et très probablement
d'ailleurs à un moment donné on en
reviendra aussi à tester les smartphones
il est capital que on fasse ce travail
sur le numérique à la fois parce que ça
prépare les élèves à s'insérer dans le
monde professionnel et dans cette grande
révolution numérique dont le patronat a
parlé à ces universités d'été mais c'est
que aussi comprenons bien que des élèves
qui dans leur univers personnel et
familial ce familiarise avec ces
technologies et après de leur propre
chef avec ces technologies s'ils
viennent au collège et que il redécouvre
le papier
la gomme et le crayon il y a un décalage
tel que le collège va leur apparaître
n'ont pas comme un lieu d'apprentissage
mais comme un lieu d'ennuis allez on va
parler de l'avenir du département alors
il y a quelques mois le gouvernement
annonçait la suppression la disparition
des conseils généraux à compter de 2021
et puis là
changement de position on ne sait pas en
tout cas le porte-parole du gouvernement
Stéphane Le Foll a déclaré que la
suppression des départements n'était pas
vraiment possible alors est-ce que ça
vous réjouit je pense que oui du coup
je n'ai jamais cru que les départements
disparaitraient j'ai essayé de faire de
la pédagogie pour expliquer parce que je
trouve ça très dangereux et très
inconscient de la part du gouvernement
que d'avoir fait croire que les élus ça
sert à rien que ça coûte de l'argent
dans une démocratie il faut des élus il
fallait que ça servait à rien par contre
que c'est vrai que ça pouvait coûter de
l'argent on est en période quand même de
quand on veut réduction des dépenses
publiques on peut comprendre que ça peut
être intéressant de réduire le
millefeuille certes mais encore une fois
si l'on décide de supprimer il faut pas
lorsque
vous avez un problème comme celui que
rencontra la France il faut pas se
tromper de diagnostic qu'est-ce qu'il y
a quand même des missions qui peuvent
donner aujourd'hui les départements tous
les départements nous sommes en
situation financière périlleuse
pas nos dépenses d'administration ce
sont les dépenses sociales qu'on nous
fait faire le gouvernement matin midi et
soir invente de nouvelles dépenses
sociales
la France a encore les moyennes de ce
pays un système de protection sociale
héritée du siècle passé
et qui ne correspond plus à nos recettes
alors bien entendu qu'il faut de la
protection sociale bien entendu qu'il
faut de la justice sociale mais encore
faut-il que ça ne soit pas de la justice
sociale à crédit c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes nous
sommes solidaires entre nous mais nous
ne sommes pas solidaires avec les
générations futures sur les évolutions
du conseil général vous l'avez évoqué en
début d'entretien vous souhaiteriez que
les lycées dépendent du conseil général
merci dépend du conseil régional c'est
parce que ce serait logique mieux gérer
parce que c'est proche
le conseiller régional à vous comme
Valérie Pécresse député qui dit qui dit
que le Conseil général socialiste
Île-de-France germal les lycées vous le
pensez aussi bien sûr mais je pense que
tous les conseils régionaux germal et
que c'est pas parce qu'il est socialiste
qui gère mal c'est parce que ça n'est
pas la bonne échelle connaissez-vous
votre conseiller général
oui connaissez-vous votre conseiller
régional
de fait non ben voilà c'est tout donc
chère
on sait pas qui responsable et si vous
allez voir un conseiller régional ils
peuvent vous répondre mais c'est pas moi
le responsable c'est ma chaîne dans un
autre département et là vous le
connaissez pas alors que votre
conseiller général quand vous allez le
voir il peut pas vous dire je vous aide
pas dans mon département il est obligé
de prendre un compte comme le maire ce
qu'on vous dit c'est très dangereux ce
qu'on voulait faire les socialistes et
heureusement qu'ils ne vont pas y
arriver parce qu'il peut pas y avoir de
démocratie sans élus proche autrement on
sombre dans autre chose c'est autre
chose je sais même pas ce que c'est je
pense que même de le savent pas et c'est
très très dangereux on ne traversera pas
la crise politique
que à travers ce pays on la traversera
pas cette crise si on s'en prend aux
élus c'est avec les élus et le peuple
c'est la démocratie c'est le peuple et
les élus les élus ils sortent du peuple
il faut pas que ça soit des systèmes
imposés par le donc les lycées au
Conseil Général donc aux choses aussi
d'autres compétences du Conseil régional
je suis d'accord pour que la compétence
économique soit transférée ce qui est en
cours au conseil régional qui soit le
chef de fil bien entendu le bassin de
vie c'est la région parisienne j'en suis
bien conscient et je pense même qu'en
région parisienne il faut que les
tailles sont mot à dire là-dessus parce
que c'est aussi stratégique la région
parisienne c'est la région capitale
c'est la capitale économique et
financière du pays donc il est pas
question de dire donnons tout au
département et vidons la région la
région doit être supprimée au conseil
régional non non la région doit exister
elle doit être un outil de coordination
moi j'ai une vision très simple de la
région parisienne si vous me le
permettez je vais essayer d'exprimer en
quelques phrases le président Sarkozy a
eu une grande idée ça s'appelait le
Grand Paris
cette grande idée du Grand Paris mérite
une grande réforme institutionnelle il
faut donc dire la métropole le Grand
Paris c'est la région et qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette région et bien cette
région c'est l'expression des élus de
terrain elle est donc composée de gens
qui ont été élus au scrutin majoritaire
donc on les connaît on connaît leur nom
ils sont rattachés un territoire de
Grand Paris on va parler
d'intercommunalités les villes devaient
se regrouper au 1er janvier 2014 ça
s'est fait plus ou moins avec le sourire
ce schéma il pourrait évoluer au 1er
janvier 2016 avec des intercommunalités
qui pourraient faire du coup plus de 200
000 habitants le Préfet de Région vient
de présenter un projet d'une grande
intercommunalité à 800 000 habitants qui
raid de plaisir Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines jusqu'à Massy alors là c'est la
grande intercommunité vous en pensez
quoi beaucoup de balles parce qu'on se
fout un peu de nous alors tout ça est
déclenché par le fait qu'on a décidé je
reviens à ma vision de la région
parisienne
faire que la Ville de Paris qui est trop
petite à l'échelle mondiale on est
d'accord va absorber les trois
départements limitrophes
Seine-Saint-Denis Val-de-Marne
Hauts-de-Seine pour faire la métropole
le problème que ça ça pose tout le monde
en convient c'est que ça consomme tous
les moyens à toute la richesse et que
donc les quatre grands départements de
la région parisienne que sont les
Yvelines le Val-d'Oise les saônes la
Seine-et-Marne se trouve un peu
marginalisé dans ce système donc on leur
dit mes enfants
on aurait pu dire regroupons les
départements après tout de par deux
non on leur dit ah ben on va créer de
grandes intercos ça ne répond pas
comment voulez-vous qu'une interco ou
même de 800 000 habitants comme on nous
l'annonce puisse être en compétition
avec une métropole à côté de 8 millions
d'habitants j'ai fait une
contre-proposition au préfet de région
je suis d'accord pour que on aille plus
loin que le simple établissement public
d'aménagement qui s'occupe du plateau de
Saclay et donc je considère que les
quatre intercommunalités concernées
peuvent se réunir non pas fusionner mais
se réunir dans une structure qui n'est
pas une nouvelle
hiérarchie fonctionnaire un peu etc mais
qui est un outil de coordination qui est
en quelque sorte un syndicat comme un
syndicat intercommunal c'est un syndicat
ouvert donc là les cadres dont vous
parlez je vais verser grand pas
et Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et c'est la
cape et je me rappelle plus le nom de
l'ordre
des Yvelines et qu'elles soient reliées
dans ce qu'on appelle un pôle
métropolitain je crois que c'est à
l'étude parce que je pense on a la
chance d'avoir avec le préfet de région
un homme très expérimenté je crois qu'il
a vraiment bien compris que nous
n'étions pas dans le refus de faire
avancer le dossier du plateau de Saclay
qui est un dossier d'intérêt national
que nous souhaitions au contraire
pouvoir le faire avancer en étant le
plus pertinent possible et que cette
fusion qu'on nous prépare aura l'effet
inverse de celle que on prétend obtenir
par intéressant donc un nouveau dossier
à suivre dossier très important merci
parmi merci et puisque nous étions avec
Pierre Bédier sachez que l'UMP apparaît
aujourd'hui unis et c'est une première
depuis longtemps en ce mois de septembre
paraît elle est 12 travaux de
l'opposition c'est un ouvrage collectif
réunissant autour de Benoît Apparu
l'ancien ministre du Logement François
Fillon Alain Juppé brissorte-feu Xavier
Bertrand Bruno Le Maire ou encore
Valérie Pécresse patronne de la
formation dans les Yvelines députés
conseillère régional vous le savez elle
a travaillé sur le volet éducation sur
ce livre on l'écoute moi j'ai choisi de
traiter le sujet de des réformes
structurelles mais des réformes si c'est
des réformes structurelles c'est des
réformes qui permettent de faire mieux
avec moins d'argent et surtout de
d'améliorer le fonctionnement de nos
services publics pour l'avenir et j'ai
choisi évidemment l'éducation je défends
depuis très très longtemps une réforme
profonde du bac et une réforme du lycée
qui permettrait de changer complètement
la mentalité de l'école française et qui
permettrait
aux élèves du secondaire de faire des
choix j'allais dire par goût et non pas
des choix subis c'est passé de 10
matières au bac 10 à 12 matières
aujourd'hui à 6 matières et
des matières qui seraient choisies de
manière personnelle par les par les
jeunes donc on casserait les filières
ESLs et on redonnerait toutes leurs
lettres de noblesse aux matières
littéraires à égalité avec les matières
scientifiques pour terminer cette
édition du 7 8 politique merci pour ce
moment c'est le nom de l'ouvrage de
l'ancienne première dame ancienne
compagne de François Hollande sortie le
4 septembre et le vampirise la rentrée
littéraire et divise c'est en tout cas
un succès commercial tiré à 200 000
exemplaires pour sa première édition il
est déjà en rupture de stock chez
l'éditeur bien que certaines librairies
aient décidé de ne pas le mettre en
rayon les autres ne peuvent en tout cas
pas répondre à la demande comme ici dans
cet enseigne de produits culturels aux
Clayes-sous-Bois
on avait commandé une centaine les gens
l'attendaient et nous le prenaient entre
les mains on n'a même pas le temps de
l'installer on avait fait on a essayé de
faire une belle installation à peine
deux heures elle était elle était par
terre et puis on avait de nombreux
appels pour des mises de côté et comment
clients donc à midi il y avait déjà plus
on a été inondé de mails de la part de
nos services centraux de la part
d'achètes comme quoi bon bah c'était des
gens rupté que les camions venaient
d'Allemagne pour pour une livraison dans
la soirée nous on était prêt à se
déplacer parce que les entrepôts sont
pas très loin ils sont dans le 78
achètent on était prêt à se déplacer
pour aller chercher nos produits ça nous
a été refusés d'habitude on a plus ce
genre d'événements sur des des
œuvres pour ado du style Harry Potter ou
Twilight ou divergente de mémoire moi
j'en ai enfin j'ai pas souvenir d'une
vente aussi rapide
propos recueilli par William elle fin de
ce numéro de rentrée je vous retrouve le
7 octobre à 18h30 pour un nouveau 7 8
politique et bien sûr chaque soir de la
semaine du lundi au vendredi à 18h pour
le journal de la rédaction très bonne
soirée